the mighty ducks game changers is a fun
series that is warmly familiar to any
adult who remembers the 90s trilogy of
mighty ducks films the callbacks to the
original movies aren't the only things
that grown-ups in the audience will pick
up on
these are the details nods and
references only adults will notice
in the mighty ducks game changers in
game on
episode 1 of game changers we meet alex
morrow in her workplace
a paralegal for a corporate law firm
alex is hurrying to get out of the
office in order
to get her son evan to practice with the
ducks but before she can make it out the
door
her boss holds her up with one last task
when alex tries to suggest a female
co-worker take on the work instead
her boss shuts the idea down with a
dispiriting comparison
alex gets compared to her co-worker as
an employee and as a hockey mom
and in both instances she's implied to
be found wanting
could we put a pin in this i have got to
go maybe stephanie could take a look
stephanie's log off she had to take her
twins to hockey practice you know she
never misses it she's a great mom
kids will be amused at work not going
alex's way but only adults will pick up
on just how real alex's predicament is
alex a working single mom is expected to
perform
above and beyond at work but she's also
expected to be a great mom who never
misses a hockey practice
if she tries to do one she can't have
the other and if she tries to do both
things
she'll come up short on both of them she
can't quite have it all
but it's clear that she's expected to
it's an impossible standard that working
women everywhere will find
all too familiar this one works so hard
and such
a great attitude scenes of the parents
at the hockey rink won't connect with
kids
beyond the obvious fact of the parents
pushing their progeny way too hard on
the ice
but any parent who has had a kid compete
in organized group sports will find
these scenes
unsettlingly familiar most parents know
there are two types of adults who get
involved in youth athletics
the ones whose kids are participating
for fun and the ones who are in it to
win it
the parents in game changers are
definitely a little exaggerated
most parents have probably not already
consulted a college counselor for their
11 year olds
still adults watching the show are
likely to either relate to alex's
laid-back approach to her kid's hockey
career
or the deeply invested hockey parents
who sign their kids up for one thousand
dollar clinics and crack of dawn
practices with private trainers
oh i'm not a trainer i'm a pediatric
sports psychologist
does no one see the insanity but me
while game changers definitely feels
more sympathetic to alex's point of view
both types of parents are vividly
portrayed moreover
both types are completely real game
changers is facing reality head-on in
this detail
in a way grown-up viewers appreciate on
the hunt for new team members
evan and nick seek out someone who keeps
beating them in an online hockey game
from his username coob13 they determined
that he must be 13 years old and managed
to sleuth out his home address
they proceed to invite themselves over
to his house and make their pitch for
him to join the team
thus jaden kubler becomes their goalie
kittens will likely accept this plotline
at face value
but adults may be horrified at the
implications
username code13 jaden kubler
our age has played this game for 10 000
hours
where are his parents first of all
there's the fact that these kids assume
that someone who has played over 10 000
hours of an online game is their age
based solely on the number in his name
for all they know coob could be a grown
adult whose morals are completely
unknown
he might not even be any good at
real-life hockey but the thought that it
may be dangerous to go to a stranger's
house without telling anyone where
they're going
doesn't seem to occur to evan or nick
then there's the fact that they go from
looking him up on their phones to
knowing his home address
even putting aside the extreme
coincidence that he happens to attend
their school
and live within walking distance of
their houses it's troubling that two
12-year-olds can find the home address
of another kid with nothing but his
first name
and an internet search engine when alex
stumbles across the ice palace
she crosses paths with gordon bombay
star of the first two mighty ducks
movies
but when she asks to use his space for
hockey practice he refuses with a line
the people who saw
all three original movies may find
surprising
here's the long and short of it i hate
hockey and i don't like kids
this line will be familiar to fans of
the films it's the same thing he says in
the first mighty ducks movie when
meeting his team for the first time
now here's the long and the short of it
i hate hawking i don't like kids
while kids may pick up on the obvious
callback if they've seen the first film
they'll likely miss what this suggests
about gordon himself
last we saw him in d3 the mighty ducks
he was leaving to be director of player
personnel
for the junior goodwill games committee
putting him in charge of their
international junior hockey program
later he returns with his lawyer hat on
arguing for the scholarships of his
former players
he leaves with a smile on his face after
witnessing their victory in the final
game
so what happened between d3 and game
changers to make gordon so bitter again
gordon was last seen accepting a dream
job to help kids around the world play
hockey
now he hates both kids and hockey again
adults will quickly realize something
significant and depressing must have
happened to undo his character
development from the first three films
adults may also notice that the show
having coach bombay take a page out of
the johnny lawrence playbook
could be an effort to grab a little bit
more of that cobra kai magic
and as always every customer leaves
with their very own bonsai tree
[Music]
much like the helicopter parents of
episode 1 aren't as far off from reality
as kids might think
neither is alex's chipper trust fall
approach to coaching
while alex is one of the protagonists of
game changers she also represents the
other side of the coin
with regards to parenting and game
changers makes it clear that different
doesn't necessarily mean
better episode 2 dusters especially
drives home how neither approach is much
fun for the kids
parents trying to engineer their kids
entire lives yes i'm trying to pull him
away from those freaks you're just as
bad as they are
just as the ducks win at all costs
approach robs the sport of joy
so too does alex's carefree who cares if
we're any good
attitude as evan points out at the end
of the episode we're just here to have
fun doesn't hold much water
if no one is having any fun because
they're getting completely annihilated
by the other team
wow okay kids will relate to evan and
the team's frustrations with alex
but may not notice that the episode
serves as a critique of winning is
nothing parenting
just as much as the previous episode is
a critique of winning is everything
parenting while both sides are a bit
exaggerated for the show's purposes
they are very much based on real
parental approaches to kid sports
game changers argues that while winning
definitely isn't everything
it's still important to at least try and
that behaving otherwise
isn't beneficial for kids most people
are probably not watching the mighty
ducks films or
shows out of a deep investment in gordon
bombay's love life but that hasn't kept
it from being a recurring theme in the
franchise
in the first film he strikes up a
romance with casey conway
charlie conway a single mom while acting
as the team's coach
they break up before the second film but
that apparently doesn't dissuade gordon
from falling for
other parents of his players it's
obvious from their first interaction in
the mighty ducks game changers
that there's a spark between gordon and
alex granted in the beginning that spark
is closer to being one of annoyance but
it grows quickly into affection
and before long it's clear that gordon
has a bit of a crush
alex spends most of the season
pretending she doesn't notice his
growing interest in her but it's hard to
miss
even for young viewers however kids are
a lot less likely
to pick up on the fact that this whole
hitting on the parents thing
is becoming a pattern for gordon for
someone who claims to be no fan of kids
he sure does seem to have a thing for
single moms
coach t gets pretty shady in game
changers episode 6.
after arranging a secret meeting with
evan he tries to convince the 12 year
old to return to the ducks
even giving him tips about how to
manipulate his mother into supporting
the decision
creepy definitely and that's not all he
does he also tries to rewrite history in
an attempt to make evan doubt his own
memory when evan pushes back on coach
t's once a duck
always a duck rhetoric reminding his
former coach that he's the one who cut
evan from the team
coach t attempts to spin a new narrative
oh kinda was a duck and then you cut me
no
i challenged you and you've risen to
that challenge
of course while evan can't rewind his
memories to remind himself what really
happened
viewers can it's obvious in episode 1
that coach t's version of events is
altering some key details
cutting evan is absolutely not meant as
a challenge coach t
cuts him because he doesn't think he's
good enough to remain on the team end of
story
okay you work hard you're good but
you're not good enough
adults will recognize this tactic as an
abusive method of psychological
manipulation
known as gaslighting which involves a
person making someone else question
their own memories or perception of
reality
sparking confusion anxiety and doubt
kids won't miss that something is weird
and how coach t
is suddenly treating evan differently
but only adults will be able to pinpoint
just how messed up his tactics are
throughout game changers we get a
glimpse of how the mighty ducks hockey
program works
and it's honestly a little strange
sophie mentioned she first started
playing when she was 5 years old
and it's clear in episode 1 that evan
has been playing on the ducks for at
least a few years in the
to 11 age bracket yet the ducks are
clearly a robust program
with many state championships there must
be an older bracket beyond the 12 to 14
one that these players eventually
graduate to
as well as brackets of younger players
working their way up
so where are all these other teams at
the spirit of the ducks gala
there is no indication of any other
players outside the 12 to 14 team
the only parents on the duck sport are
the parents of the 12 to 14 players
and they've all been part of the board
for years indicating that members don't
have to be parents of players within a
certain bracket
so do the ducks just spin up a new team
once a decade with whatever
five-year-olds happen to be interested
in hockey at the time
that doesn't seem practical or
sustainable and certainly wouldn't earn
them as many championship banners as we
see displayed around their home rank
an adult viewer can't help but wonder
where all the other ducks are
and why we don't ever hear about them
when the power goes out at the ice
palace in episode 7
pond hockey gordon's solution is to take
the don't bothers to a nearby pond to
practice on the frozen ice
he pulls out his odd sixth sense from
the first movie of knowing how much
weight naturally frozen ice can support
and assures a doubtful alex that the
kids will be safe skating on the pond
somehow that's enough to convince her
sure enough the ice holds firm
and the kids come together as a team in
the great outdoors
however while gordon manages to convince
alex to let her kid on the ice
they never run this plan by any of the
other don't bothers parents
it doesn't make me nervous at all we're
totally not gonna fall through the ice
moreover it's highly unlikely that those
permission forms they signed
consented to alex taking their kids out
onto the questionable surface of a
naturally frozen pond luckily nothing
bad happens on the pond but still
alex risks parents pulling kids from the
team as a person in the legal profession
alex really should consider more angles
beyond gordon's spidey sense
before agreeing to his plan in head
games
the don't bothers are nearly sidelined
when gordon admits to coach t that he
received an
ncaa suspension a decade earlier and
coach t
reports him to the tournament board
since the state tournament is an ncaa
certified event
all coaches are required to be ncaa
approved in order for their teams to
compete
however alex successfully argues that
the don't bother
should be exempt from this rule since
their team was never scouted
and gordon is allowed to continue
coaching it's a victorious moment
but adults may be left wondering what
the don't bothers would have done
if a scout ever had shown up at one of
their games since it seems highly
unlikely that alex is an ncaa-approved
coach either
after all she volunteers to coach solely
because no one else is willing to do it
she knows nothing about hockey and
spends the whole season flying by the
seat of her pants
that means that if the don't bothers
coaches hadn't been saved on a lucky
technicality
they would have been disqualified from
states before even stepping foot on the
ice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows on
disney plus are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one